you know what's wrong with they be
hearing tell them bro yeah why do they
be hearing know what's wrong
with I'll be in bed as bars no I'll be
I'll be I'll be in bed and then like's
like did you hear that I'm like stop
[Music]
listening what do you guys think what do
you think scary why is it scary why do
you think it's not scary is that color
pencil it's just color pencil Nick any
kind of picture like that scary if you
saw that a haunted house would you be
scared a little bit I feel like that's
because you're putting it in the context
of a haunted house what have you saw in
a non- haunted house that looks like one
of those things where if you it's like a
hologram where if you go down it's like
the devil and if you pop up and it's
like a little it looks like there's
horns there that do you believe in like
cursed paintings do you believe in
cursed um I I don't know but your boy
not going to test it out I'll say that
I'm not going to say I'm not going to
how would you test it out I don't know
yeah does she have a only fans
maybe that's tight that's that's good
tight that's good well the last owner of
this painting her name is Zoe Elliot
brown right she said that when she got
this painting right afterwards she
started getting chased by an
unidentified black figure that's scary
like a [__] Shadow I don't know she
just racist think or she's racist there
some people there are some people that
think like every object has like energy
in it you know I don't know like when I
get this [__] Kirkland water bottle
oh my God I believe in like frequency
and energies and stuff yeah so like you
know I think if you have a painting
that's been passed on from you know dark
house to dark house and weird stuff I
tell you this when I get secondhand
furniture and clothing I feel like I
somehow get a piece of who owned it kind
of like both the good and the bad you
get some of their energy yeah like I
remember sitting on this rocking chair
and I'm like
I feel like a grandma on this [__]
rocking chairs are cursed items though
that's a classic classic Horror Story
[__] bro you see rocking chair just move
by itself imagine you see that in your
living room at like 2: a.m. you'd be
scared and that sound too that sound is
just so eer even more powerful though
than
energy price talk to him if you Chinese
right you go oh what the hell this house
is haunted man and they're like I'll
sell it to you for 50 G's oh my God
thank you what a beautiful house escrow
tomorrow cuz they disclosing that they
don't give a [__] cuz it's kind of like
I can live with that yeah it's not that
bad speaking of price I don't mind the
ghost so this lady this lady say she uh
it was haunted right and so she brought
it back to the place where she got it
from which was a charity shop it was
actually the second time it was returned
oh my God why don't they burn this [__]
well so inste I'm not going to burn it
I'm not going to be the one what she
ended up doing right was talking about
it and then it ended up going viral
online in whatever area of of was there
like 10 other people that were like
[__] that [__] hot at me too she she
wrote she's back sold or or the the shop
the charity shop said she's back sold
twice and returned twice are you brave
enough and then eventually oh that's a
genius marketing oh my God and
eventually they were able to sell it for
$2,000 hot Dam baby to some weird Ghost
Hunter people are dumb
asses see that's why those scary movies
it's always white people getting duped
yeah Asians go 2,000 no way that's not
my price how about how about
$25 if we were to get stereotypical it
is always white people that want to
investigate can you explain thaten
that's why Colleen's here go ahead
Colleen's going to speak on everybody
cleen speaking on speak for the whites
across the world I would not
investigate you're like what's that you
you say that but part of me is like I I
think you would though I think I think
your DNA to look and investigate like
you'll be compelled once the the
situation presents itself no if it's
something that I can't get away from are
you afraid of ghosts afraid I mean
what's the situation okay so like
there's a pounding in your attic right
and then you pull down the stairs and
you hear the pounding and it's all black
out there and you're like I'm going to
go investigate yeah yeah yeah I think
you would investigate is the thing I'm
closing that door and I'm I'm locking it
I'm going but then it goes
again and it
goes I'm getting in my car and I'm
driving out of that house no what if it
goes colie oh then I'd be like oh they
know me oh it's me it's me they know my
name the only one that I have Colleen
Kathleen Kayla the all all the above you
know what I don't my name is kayin by
the way you know those scary movies what
I don't understand is like you don't
have to make it so scary right if you're
in a house and it's at night all you got
to do is turn on the all the lights turn
on all the lights of the room as you go
and then it's like it's not as scary
then okay no but that's why they always
go like this and it doesn't work or yeah
then you [__] play Britney Spears you
think if you play Britney Spears while
you're investigating it's it's got so
scary it's all about the vibe you got to
set the SE bro you can't let your mind
go there open open the fridge let the
light come out oh baby baby Joe Joe
should test this Theory and like Ghost
Hunt at the most like haunted places in
the world but you have like all your
strategies you have like if you're
playing early 2000s pop music right
while playing Slender Man how scary is
that Slender Man may not come out I play
like a Pokemon theme
like there's no winning scenario of
investigating cuz either you investigate
and it's nothing it's like okay cool
there's nothing or you investigate and
there's something and now you're
involved in this spooky this
entanglement but what if you don't
investigate and there was something and
that something now goes and kills you
yeah if you don't
investigate you can't fall asleep oh
[__] that's what I'm saying peace of
mind okay so then I will delegate to
somebody
else like what Hannah did to me in Vegas
what did Hannah do to you we were
staying at my friend's house that was
half constructed and then some loud
noise happened in the cuz he was letting
me sleep for free half constru what does
it mean there's no roof they were
building out new rooms in the back okay
so it's like the it was a house it was
just we were in the portion of the house
that was nice and then we heard a crash
or like a drop or whatever and she goes
go check it out and I'm all like
[__] all right there's nothing there bab
we saw a dead pigeon just a dead isn't
that a bad Omen don't they say dead bird
is the omen is that more of like a crow
or some [__] that's a little more
ominous right but pigeon works I think
dead anything yeah yeah cuz that was
scared me a little bit like what was the
nature of the death was it like just
like lying there or was it like the neck
was [__] turned and knotted oh my God
I don't know that thing was like
fossilized cuz you know the Vegas Sun
dries up the bird so been there for a
while it wasn't wrong I'm my pasta it
was there for like 20 minutes dude it
was there for a while you know what's
wrong with [__] they'd be [__]
hearing tell them bro yeah why do they
be here and Sh I know what's wrong with
[__] I'll be in bed as bars I'll be
I'll be I'll be in [__] bed and then
like's like did you hear that I'm like
stop
listening I'm so glad you listening for
tff does not do that that's so true
though I hear I hear everything oh my I
was about to fall asleep and then you
[__] be listening to [__] yeah I
don't hear what you hear just put
headphones on go to sleep why you so
Noy damn you're saying Tiff doesn't do
that she doesn't do that stop listening
stop hearing watch tonight she's going
to be like can you go check on that I'll
be like [__] did you hear that what was
that yeah yeah yeah Tiff doesn't do that
thank God like if it doesn't register
immediately I just go oh it's just
noises
again just just no no specifics it's
just noises you know what I do go out
for is car crashes oh hell yeah bro I'm
grabbing I'm putting my pants on I'm
running out the door what bro the other
day heard a scar boom right and I'm like
oh [__] I ran out there like the ice
cream man came was coming I [__] went
out the balcony I saw this [__] lady
she hit this boy on a moped the moped
was [__] up the bumper was gone he was
just standing there and she goes are you
okay and then he was just moving his
moped and I'm like damn this fo didn't
die yeah that's crazy I I also listen
for fights like like your neighbors are
fighting mhm that that's a good
one list I don't like it when I have to
help [__] ear to the door and [__] I
don't like it when I have to help I mean
sometimes you just hear them with just
being in your place like a verbal
argument verbal argument have you all
experienced a Karen in like a Caren
moment in real life a million times
benefited me oh this is when I used to
live in Downtown LA there's a Starbucks
that everyone would go to cuz I think
it's like walking distance to like all
the the like highrises where people work
and stuff and then the pile up started
going out the door onto the sidewalk and
then I was I think I was like maybe
person number 15 and I'm like [__] this
Starbucks is taking forever I'm just
standing there like a normal person then
this Karen who just shows up this is
unacceptable why is there a line like
this and then she was like and she goes
up she she looks at me like you know
what's going on I'm like I don't know
I'm just sitting here she goes you you
you and you come with me we're going to
fix this and I was like all right so I
go up she goes to the front talks to the
manager gets us for our drinks made
first and then she takes off the line is
still there I'm like I don't know she
just just like hey look what are you
doing you're like ruining the customer
experience whatever just like [__]
you guys need to hurry up just some
Caren [__] and because I was randomly
there and I was like one of the four
like volunteers or whatever we all got
our Cofe I was like this this is kind of
tight I'm that's why it's dope to have a
Karen in your crew sometimes it it does
help as long as they're on your side on
your side on your side on your side and
you don't want to be the Karen you just
want the Ken to do the Ken for you Jason
I don't even know I don't you want to be
cared for I don't even know what to say
wow thank you thank you are they strong
Aunt
Karen end the
[Laughter]
[Music]
video